hello everyone and happy women's day
everyone uh fide posted this game under
twitter feed and uh after i saw it i was
extremely impressed by it and decided to
show it i know we're in the middle of
the morphe saga and we really got into
it but
this game deserves a a showing as i've
never seen it i haven't shown it on the
channel and i don't know if anyone else
uh
has shown it probably has but i i
haven't seen it so
chances are some of you haven't as well
and well you are going to enjoy this one
because it's a really really
a brutal attacking masterpiece so
without further ado let's check it out
it's uh
israeli grand master alan grimfeld uh
versus judith polgar
the game was played in 1989 in haifa
israel
and i think uh grimfeld got his
grandmaster title uh right about that
time but you did
was not a grand master just yet he rece
she received her grandmaster title in
1991
so regardless of uh all the facts the
the game is really awesome so let's dive
straight into it
so without further ado uh d4 is what was
played uh
by uh mr alan grimfield uh we have
knight to f6 by unit
c4 and now c5 immediately striking uh
with
the benoni defense we have d5 and going
for the absolute
sharpest uh attack uh that is the b5 the
banco gambit
uh we have knight to f3 and not
accepting the the gambit right away and
now g6 you did not prepare stephen kind
of her dark square bishop on this long
diagonal
and here c captures on b5 now we have
a6 unit offers yet another pawn for some
extra rapid development and now knight
the c3
accepting this pawn isn't all that
popular but nowadays b6
is um is the go to move you you hinder
black's development a little bit
and you uh say you're not interested in
grabbing any more material so instead
after a6 knight to c3 now this was the
i i think the top move back then and now
a captures on b5
uh but now you doesn't go after the b5
pawn rather she plays d6 and it's a
really really
uh crazy position where it's hard to
even say what's what's good for black
and well you could you could let
the the engine crunch this for for a
very long time bishop to b7 uh seems to
be the
way to continue this for for black
simply giving this knight an outpost on
e4
also grabbing hold of this long diagonal
is never is never bad now but here unit
went for bishop to g7 instead
and what do you what do you play here uh
so here we have
e4 so uh continuing the attack now e5 is
coming
but instead of just uh preventing this
with something like bishop to b7 and
then if uh
if uh grenfell goes for this e5 idea
then the knight can come to e4
uh unit even invites this and you do
just castles here
so what do you play here uh really
really uh amazing position
e5 is played and now knight to g4
so again the e5 pawn is attacked twice
but here comes bishop
to g5 putting pressure on e7 and here
you did uh
not really caring about pawn characters
or bishop characters
just plays knight captures on e5 and
this is just an amazing position
uh where white already has the
opportunity to capture the pawn here the
problem is
it's not all that easy to do this here
uh grandfather played uh bishop captures
on e7
pawn capture sun e7 might be a little
bit better the problem is after pawn
captures and rook to e8 you don't really
get to grab the queen because if you
capture the queen knight captures on f3
is checkmate it's a double check from
the knight end from the rook the knight
prevents the king from escaping to d2
and that's game over
so here after this d captures on e7 if
it was played rook to e8 uh it's a
really really crazy position where white
has to figure out how to continue this
whether to capture the knight where to
capture on b if i were to capture with
the bishop
so it is a very complicated position so
i guess grandfather wanted to
keep it a bit more simple he played
bishop characters on e7
seems to be just as winning uh but now
again
rook to e8 again with the same idea if
the queen is captured knight captures an
f3 is again
checkmate so instead after this rook to
e8 we have
bishop captures on b5 and now you did
just continues development
knight to c6 uh sorry the other night
and then knight to c6
uh the queen again is uh
not it's not possible to capture because
now it would
simply be uh the king would be in line
of uh attack of the rook
so here white castles now the queen can
be captured but now ud just grabs the
bishop so
knight captures an a7 d captures on e7
and now
rook captures on e7 uh so here we have
queen to d5 attacking the rook here on
a8
and you did defend it rook to a5 we have
queen captures on c5
grabbing that pawn and now knight to a6
so
you're definitely getting a lot of rapid
development uh and
so far she's only down one pawn so queen
to c4 getting the queen out of the way
and now
knight to c7 re-maneuvering attacking
the bishop
and also preparing maybe some d5 ideas
in the future so here a4
cementing that bishop on b5 and here
udit just eliminates it with
knight captures pawn captures and now a
trade of rook so rook captures on a1
rook capture 71
and now white is still up upon but it's
a double b pawn so it is a little bit
easier for black to play this so here
bishop to b7 uh putting the bishop on
this very long diagonal
and now queen to f4 by black by white
we have h6 and now h3 both players
make a safety square for the king we
have king to h7
and now rook to d1 we have
f5 by unit advancing those pawns in
front of the king a little bit but you
have to go for the attack you're down
upon and you still have the bishop pair
and the bishop pair is extremely strong
for for attacking purposes
so knights the d5 attacking the rook
here and here
just rook to e2 we have b3
as the b2 pawn is under attack so b3 and
now judith attacks it from behind
rook to b2 and now queen to d6 and you
get this position where you can feel
that
white is uh the white is very powerful
here white has many pieces in front of
the black king and queen
and it's very hard for for uh for black
to even make a move
uh because if you move the queen then
ideas like knight to f6
check are coming and you don't really
want to part with this bishop uh if you
go for something like rook captures on
b3 then knight to e5 and already this is
a
terrible position to be in uh your g6
square is being uh threatened and if you
play something like bishop captures then
of course queen captures on e5
and again knight to f6 is coming it's a
it's a really bad position
and all the trades of course go in
white's favor if the bishop captures
queen captures
uh the rook is under attack this is
defended this will be captured so
it's uh it's a it's a really really
tough position to play
for example queen to g8
if you want to defend the rook or maybe
not even queen to g8 maybe you could
just move the rook let's say you try
something like rook here
then comes queen to f7 that's the
problem you have to play something like
this and after the king moves rook
captures on d7 that's a game over
there's no defending this
so black's position is uh really really
tough to hold but you have to
uh you have to find a a correct uh
uh correct continuation so here bishop
captures on d5
is the optimal line as it eliminates one
of white's attackers we have queen
captures on d5
rook captures was also possible i guess
i guess uh grenfell just wanted to keep
that rook on the back rank not allowing
any checks because you have to be a
little bit careful here
uh if check is delivered then maybe the
bishop can somehow find his way over to
the e5 square
uh you you have to be a little bit
careful here so here
queen captures and d5 was played but now
queen
to b6 maybe the queen was better on d6
just guarding against this queen to b6
idea because now unit is honing down on
this f2 pawn
so knight to d4 defending against this
and here that you did just goes queen to
c7 and queen to c7
uh sets up a deadly trap and it's very
very hard to spot this trap because uh
white failed to do so here you have to
play something like
queen to f7 try and get uh get some sort
of an attack going on but here
uh uh we have h4 preparing h5 to kind of
bust open black's position maybe weaken
the f5 pawn
uh but now the position is actually
completely lost for white so feel free
to pause the video
and win this game for you while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
completely elusive idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
a
rook to d2 really really an
awesome move and it really shows just
how how a seemingly
safe position can be completely
completely lost and now
there's really not all that much to do
if you capture the rook it's
uh not just that black wins back the
rook with queen to c1 check but also
after the king
runs away you're gonna play queen
captures here and now
the knight is lost as well there's no
wait for for you
not to save the knight you can't move it
because then the queen falls
and of course after captures and
captures white can still
offer some resistance but it's not going
to be enough the the extra bishop is
just too much
and you already have this square covered
you have to move the queen black will
very easily consolidate and that's just
a victory so here uh uh grenfell
decided not to capture on d2 and um
well yeah it loses the game he tried
rook to e1
but now is it just a free piece so rook
captures on d4 was played
we have queen to f7 trying to organize
sound counter play maybe go for a mating
attack here
but now rook captures an h4 with ideas
of queen to h2
so g3 was played attacking the rook and
now rook to e4
trying to trade off one of white's
attackers and now as now white only has
the queen and the rook
so rook to d1 preparing to capture on d7
and now queen to c2 offering this pawn
for
uh for a deadly attack because now if
the rook is if rook captures on d7
look the e1 check and now there's not
much to do king g2
queen to e4 check and now uh whatever
you play it's just game over
if you go here then this will be
checkmate if you go here then this will
be checkmate if you
push f3 then again queen to e2 checking
h3 and rook the h1 is checkmate
so everything is checkmate here so after
this queen to c2 move
uh we have queen captures on d7
unfortunately for white you cannot go
rook captures on d7
and now queen captures on b3 just
eliminating one of the pawns
the white black doesn't have to hurry
anywhere white is the one who's down
material
so king g2 and now comes rook to e5
preparing to grab uh
white's last piece of counter play uh we
have rooked the d6
now uh rook to d6 is a very tricky idea
but it doesn't work even if you just
captured the pawn
uh queen to f7 going after the g6 square
doesn't work because just queen here and
you you defend everything it's not a
problem uh but you
tries to keep it as simple she plays a
queen to b1
or rather not not simple she she tries
to complicate things
uh so what do you play here here queen
to f7 was played
white uh is preparing this and is hoping
for some
not not so much the checkmate you did
but at least uh
get some sort of a perpetual maybe
because uh she will be
forced to guard against checkmate and
maybe then you can make use of your
extra pawn but unit finds the amazing f4
f4 is just crushing uh so what do you do
here
uh problem is if you capture with the
pawn then the h5 square has now been
vacated for the rook rook to h5 and
there is no defense queen to h1 will be
checkmate
and even if you try to escape let's say
king to f3 just rook to f5 you could
even capture the pawn
or play rook to f5 doesn't really matter
black is completely winning here
so after f4 we have rook to d7 again
threatening checkmate but now comes
judy's idea when she played f4 the real
move was
f3 with check sacrificing this pawn
uh before for some very serious threats
now if uh
king captures queen to e4 is checkmate
for those of you who are new to chess
you should remember this pattern this uh
sort of uh
sort of a boomerang pattern here when
the queen
delivers uh check if the king is on a
light square you need points on dark
squares and then it's a sort of a
sort of a checkmate here so maybe a nice
thing to remember
so instead after f3 check uh we have
queen captures on f3
unfortunately you don't have anything
else it came to h3 also is insufficient
just queen to h1 check
and it's a nice king hunt king g4 queen
to h5 checking to f4 and g5 will be
checkmate
so like i said after f3 check you did uh
sorry
uh uh grenfell captured with uh the
queen queen captures on f3 but not just
queen captures on b5 and now white
really has no counter play
uh white did repeat queen to f7 uh to
threaten checkmate but
it's uh it is insufficient queen the c6
check was played
and it was in this position that alan
grimfield resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
although it's a very very interesting
position
i will show uh two lines because one is
extremely complicated
problem is if you go h3 then okay the
the the win is
very very easy just queen h1 check king
g4 h5 check king f4 and then
g5 will be checkmate so the bishop
covers the rook and
the king has nowhere to go uh but there
is the very tricky after queen to c6
check had this um after after this was
played
uh f3 and now it's not so simple uh
rook the e2 is insufficient because king
f1 and the white gains the
very important tempo the rook is under
attack and also you're threatening
checkmate
so the only move that wins here for udit
is actually queen to see to check
king to h3 and now rook to h5 with
check king to g4 now rook to g5 with
check king back to h3 and now queen to
c3
defending against checkmate and now
although it seems very dangerous
rook to d8 threatening queen to g8
checkmate now you
you need to find the only winning move
h5 so this is
uh how it's done and now white no longer
has anything queen g8 check you're going
to play king to h6
and now rook to d7 again putting
pressure on the bishop
but now just queen to a1 keeping defense
of the bishop here
and now threatening checkmate and this
is just it once
the king makes a few more moves it's
just h4
or or pretty much anything if g4 h3
would check king captures and now queen
to f1 with
check and that's it king h4 queen to f2
check king h3 queen captures with
check and now after king to h2 finally
the king is in a dark square
bishop to e5 with check king g1 and now
of course rook captures on g4 with
checkmate
so it's very interesting it's some 13
moves from the position where where
grandfather resigned uh but it is very
interesting so so i decided to show it
so on move 40 queen to c6 check was
played and it was in this position that
alan grimfield resigned the game
and what an amazing attacking game by by
judith polgar
uh so this was the era before engines
where you could play anything
and you know uh it was such a such a
great attacker that she did play
anything and she crushed a lot of
players with her
uh with her amazing style so really
really an awesome game and that
rook to d2 move uh it was just um
because it's similar to
how the the the great magician from riga
played uh he constantly
made problems for his opponents problem
after problem after problem
and then opponents had to waste a lot of
time calculating how to how to deal with
the problem
and then at one at one point you were
low on time there was another problem
not enough time too many problems and
then you know the position just uh
completely uh you know sinks and such
was
the case here after this h4 was played
you'd found rook to d2 and that's just
it
uh wha what an amazing move uh so yeah
i hope you guys enjoyed that a very nice
game fide suggested for uh women's
international day
i really hope you enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank emmanuel felipe
kim farnik david kimura sergius gassier
and jill williams
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
uh jill also has a birthday so happy
40th birthday hope you
enjoy it and win a lot of chess games uh
so yeah
like i said as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here
i thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the morphe saga we are going into that
wild game for
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day